hey Roger here from Google cloud and in
this video we'll have a look at how
developers can extend G suite to build
seamless solutions enabling users of
popular tools like Gmail chat and drive
to work faster easier and smarter
specifically we'll look at an end-to-end
solution that highlights newer developer
technologies like G suite add-ons chat
BOTS and accelerated mobile pages for
email by showcasing different types of
integrations that developers can build
with G suite we hope to inspire you to
build your own so let's get started meet
Anu the manager of a customer service
team at another Corp she receives an
email from one of her customers
altostrat who wants help resolving a
nagging issue inconsistent access to the
payment portal obviously resolving this
in a timely manner is key in the email
from the customer we can see a couple of
key pieces of information the issue
number and of course the customer name
as a developer you can leverage that
information in the context of the email
to build applications that can really
benefit the manager here we can see how
a new launches her CRM add-on in Gmail
without having to switch applications
log into another system and risk losing
focus and flow she can quickly triage
the customer to see important details
such as key contacts and the type of
service contract that they have next
still within the CRM add-on in Gmail and
you can see that altostrat is also an
important sales prospect with a couple
of big deals on the table now that Anu
understands the customer better it's
time to dig in on the issue that they're
having Anu has another add-on available
in Gmail where she can quickly
understand the history and status of the
issue note the add-on use the context of
the issue number from the email so Anu
didn't have to retype it or look it up
in another system with a closer look
Anu discovers that the issue had been
open in the past but was not yet
assigned to a technician to resolve it
in order to get this back on track a new
takes action to escalate the issue and
receive immediate attention by changing
its priority to a critical PZero right
within the add-on a new can also add an
explanation of the changes in a custom
comment now she needs to assign someone
to cover the issue given the urgency
sending out an email to the team may not
be fast enough so while still within
Gmail a new switches over to using chat
to quickly reach everyone in the
customer care team the other chatroom a
new invokes the team's Kanban bot chat
bot with a simple @mention and the
custom-built chat bot responds with
everyone's availability pulling from the
team's resource planning back-end app
quickly a new sees that guru is not
fully tasked and pains him directly
asking if he can help
[Music]
once he confirms that he can a new uses
another custom chat bot to assign the
task directly to guru from within the
conversation making sure that it's
immediately signed and recorded now that
we've seen how Anu was able to triage
and assign the issue let's take a look
at how our customer service rep can use
GCE extensions to help resolve the
customer issue now that the task has
been assigned to guru when he checks his
inbox he sees the email notifying him of
the assignment however the email itself
is a little unique as you can see here
by the lightning bolt designation it's a
dynamic email which is using the amp for
email spec and Gmail what makes this
interesting is guru can interact with
this email much like he would issue
tracking application but once again
without having to leave his inbox for
example he can browse the details of the
issue see related documents that might
be useful and even review the history of
the issue up to that point guru can
quickly see the comments the manager
added when escalating this issue for the
customer then right inside the email
guru can acknowledge that he's accepting
the issue being assigned to him saving
time and allowing the team to know that
he's got it covered the power of the
dynamic email becomes very apparent as
you can see guru's acceptance is
instantly displayed in the body and the
activity history of the original email
there's even an inline UI in the email
where guru can leave his own comment
where he logs that he has a good idea of
what the issue is when the issue
tracking generated this dynamic email it
also added a folder and provided a link
to the resolution template using the
drive API saving the customer service
rep time in locating documents while
ensuring they use the correct templates
and store them correctly within Drive
now let's fast forward so when guru has
worked through the problem and wants to
record the process and close out the
issue the customer service team guru
works in stores all customer documents
in a shared drive on Google Drive it's
here where guru will wrap up the process
of capturing steps and outcomes of the
issue but like we saw before with Gmail
and how you can leverage add-ons with
context you can do the same with Google
Drive as well
the same add-on written and published
once works across all G suite so after a
quick scan of the doc to make sure it's
all complete guru connects us to add-on
and drive and change the status to
closed without ever having to leave G
suite and that's it
problem solved as you can see G suite
enables developers to provide solutions
that can integrate complex processes and
data seamlessly into G suite the
solutions you can build can reduce
context switching improve workflow and
make it easier for users and teams to
get things done if you'd like to learn
more check out the links in the
description below and don't forget
subscribe to our youtube channel for
more great content
[Music]